Shareen Williams joining us he works for
pro football talk.com covering the
Cowboys shermeen thanks for joining us
on short notice
let's start with Jason Witten when did
the Cowboys find out about Monday Night
Football and what did Jerry Jones say to
Jason Witten to make him maybe hold off
on this announcement well he talked to
Jerry earlier in the month when it
looked like he was gonna get an offer
from ESPN and and said hey this may
become an type deal but then they
started offseason workouts and you know
the Cowboys thought that he was going to
come back and then obviously Chris
Mortensen's report on Friday kind of
leaked asleep the word and and put the
Cowboys in a position where they called
Jason went in and said hey what's going
on and he told them that he's playing
the offer and and they think they can
still talk him out of it I don't know
that that's gonna happen you know it's
Bill Parcells and I think originally
mark believed he said once you're
thinking about retirement you're retired
and so I think that most people expect
him to retire but the Cowboys are still
holding out hope that they can talk him
into coming back they have no
replacement for him well that leads me
to the question about the draft in the
second round and the Eagles jump up and
get the kid out of South Dakota State do
you think Dallas was zeroing in on him
given the witan news I don't I think
they probably I'm graduating from that
school next week with my master's degree
or into this weekend and I've seen the
kid play a few times at least on TV and
and he can play and I think that's
probably who they should have gone and
gotten but instead they wait till the
fourth round and get don't jilt who
could become a fine football player but
he's not ready to step in for Jason
Witten out and the forest see if the
four tight ends they have on the roster
right now have nine total catches for
their career I mean they just don't have
a guy they can count on to step in and
Jason Wynn's roll and be the tight in
that say that Jason was even even in his
last days even after he'd lost a step
last year he still with a better tight
end at the core tight ends they have on
the roster right now how good do you
think Witten can be as an analyst I
think he'll be very good as an analyst I
mean he was always one of our go-to guys
in the locker room you know he's a good
talker now I didn't think Romo would
as good as he is and he's been great I
think Witten will be great so honestly I
don't know what I'm talking about but
he's always wanted to go to guys and
lock him you kind of look to those guys
to be analysts especially coming from
the Cowboys we know we we've seen Troy
Aikman do it now Tony Romo do it and
Daryl Johnson and Michael Irvin and all
those guys and so I he's one of the guys
you kind of look to and say he's going
to be really good at this because he's
such a good talking Locker you have to
learn to put it in soundbite yeah and
that's what Romo learned right away and
he wasn't good at that locker room and
when it's not either wit and win talks
for minutes and minutes and he's gonna
have to learn to talk and sound bites I
think he can do that
yeah and and I'm just fascinated by you
know the Cowboys getting that news and
what Jerry Jones could possibly say to
Jason Witten to entice I if I'm Jason
Witten called me and said what would you
do I'd say run to that Monday Night
Football gig don't turn around don't
even think twice well they don't come
open I mean if he goes another year we
all know it's 38 he's entering the end
of his career now he's got maybe one
more year in him maybe two you're not
gonna get one of those premièred gigs in
the NFL if you wait and I think that's
kind of what he's weighing and I think
that's why he ends up retiring and the
Cowboys better be prepared for that
they're obviously not prepared on the
roster and I don't know if they have
plans to go trade for a Titan or what
they think they're gonna do but but they
better find a plan to replace him
because I don't think he's coming back
and and I do think they are still trying
to talk him into coming back at least
that Jason Garrett's trying to talk them
into condi I think you know in curious
more like a dad to him and I think Jerry
is listening to him I'm not sure Jerry's
trying to talk him into coming back I
think he Jerry's where you are kind of
saying what's best for you let's think
about what's best for you
and that's what is best for Jason Witten
for two four and a half million a year
probably doing a Monday night gig is
better than where he is now at the end
of his career
great stuff serene thank you and
congratulations on getting your your
doctorate there thank you so much
the Jackrabbits that Sherine williams
chute covers the Cowboys for more Dan
Patrick show too
it's channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]